l'éternité peut être une malédiction les pertes que vous
avez dû subir suis-je à nouveau à court de
choses à vivre pour perdre son but
qui fait mal je ne m'en soucierais pas
j'essaie de vous trouver depuis plus d'un
an
mon employeur est en train de mourir  il veut te remercier
de lui avoir sauvé la vie
c'est un honneur de rencontrer le Wolverine
ce n'est plus qui je suis je ne t'ai pas
envoyé chercher uniquement pour te remercier Logan je
voulais te rembourser un cadeau égal à la
vie que tu m'as donnée tu as
J'ai lutté assez longtemps, notre entreprise peut faire tout ce que je peux
faire de toi, heureusement avant
ce qu'ils m'ont fait, ce que je suis
ne peut pas être annulé,
n'en sois pas si sûr
[Musique]